Connor Reed from North Wales was working
in a school in Wuhan when he began to
feel unwell he would become the first
known British man to catch the corona
virus take me back to November 25th day
one you get a cold the end of November I
was feeling and just a normal cold and
the problem with this virus is it
progresses in stages so you'll have a
cold you'll get better and you'll get
worse you'll get better then you get
worse again it's quite possible Connor
just happen to catch his cold several
days before he was then struck by the
corona virus just described the symptoms
and where it really starts to hit I was
feeling achy I just wanted to curl up
into a ball I had ear problems and and
no sinus problems where it was it felt
like there was a balloon being blown up
and in my face I was raking coughing it
was terrible and it was happening so
much and lost my voice and and I've lost
my voice a few times just just in a
little bit but this was it was gone I
couldn't make any sound at all for most
people who catch the virus it won't get
any worse than this and may not even get
as bad but for Connor the scariest part
was when he began to struggle with his
breathing it was a case of going to bed
and waking up not being able to breathe
and me it scared me because breathing's
necessities a life like if you have the
flu you really you feel like you're
going to die be you're really not but
when your lungs getting affected that's
where it scared me and I couldn't take a
full breath I know the breaths I did
take it sounded like I was breathing
through a back
connor was diagnosed with pneumonia
despite living in what would become the
epicenter of the virus as yet the local
authorities were unaware that Wuhan in
China was incubating a nasty new virus
that would spread across the globe
it was weeks before Connor was told he
had Co vid 19
he's now recovered from the illness but
his adopted City is still struggling
with strict rules on how often you can
leave the house at the moment
one person is allowed to leave their
house every three days and that's just a
purchased necessities there are some
shops that are open they've blocked the
door off and you tell them what you want
they put it into a bag and then they
past the back - you want a stick and
just to avoid that personal contact
Connor says he always thought he would
pull through but having experienced it
he can see why the virus could be deadly
for some Jason Ferrell Sky News